نبقى مع اليوم العالمي للمراه هذه المره
من لبنان وعن المراه اللبنانيه مبروكه
كوميديا مسرحيه جسدت باسلوب مضحك مبكى وضع
المراه في ظل عقم قوانين الاحوال الشخصيه
في لبنان صرخه واحده وحدت ثلاث سيدات على
خشبه المسرح رفضنا الاحكام المسبقه التي
يطلقها المجتمع بحق المراه المطلقه هؤلاء
السيدات اعلن انتفاضه على عادات وتقاليد
لا تزال تجبرهن على الخضوع لسلطه الرجل
وايضا تحرمهن من الحمايه والمساواه في
الحقوق والعداله الاجتماعيه من لبنان
رينادويه رافقت المسرحيه حتى وصولها الى
دبي
[موسيقى]
وين
لك
اه ما عرفتي طلقنا
اوكي المفروض حلو عربي نحن حبينا نلعب على
هذا الكلام خصوصا انه قبل عاملين مسرحيه
اسمها زنود الست
وبتحكي عن زند الاساس بالبيت عن عن مراه
قاعده بالبيت هلا هالمره عن ست البيت
فهالمراه عم نحكي عن المراه المطلقه فمن
زود الست الى مفروكه لانه انفركت وفركتها
خلاص خلاص اعطيني هيدي الست
اه ما في غير مبروكه لعب على الحلو كمان
فيه نوع من السركاس لانه حلو انه بتفكري
انه شي كتير لذيذ وفارس وهيك هو بيطلع
يعني المسرحيه مثل ما قالت كانوا عم
بيقولوا انه كوميدي بس بذات الوقت فيها
شيء مر عم نحكي عن قصص مهمه هي يعني بذات
الوقت بتسلي بس فيها مساج قوي ما بحب اجلي
الولاد حضانه مشتركه يعني منشوف شو الانسب
لالهن ومنقر سوا لا كيف لا مفروكه هي
مسرحيه كوميديه
واخترنا اسلوب الكوميدي لانه بالنسبه
لالنا الكوميدي فيها توصل
مساج بطريقه كثير مباشره يعني فيها كتير
تدقر العالم بلا ما تخفف من جديه الموضوع
العرس يعني
مثل كل مره يعني مثل كل انسان فيه كل هذا
البارز فنحنا منفرجيهم بهذه الطريقه
وبنفرجيكي كيف اوقات
بصير في مشاكل يعني كيف الواحد هو بيكون
في مشاكل بين حاله واوقات بالعكس بحن على
حاله
عملنا معروف احكيني عربي لانه ما بفهم
عليك
مفروكه هي قصه كل امراه وقفت الاعراف
وايضا القوانين سدا امام عداله قضيتها
سواء المتعلقه بالطلاق وما يتفرع عنه من
حق في الحضانه او ما يرتبط بنظره المجتمع
اليها واطلاق اداناته المسبقه بحقها لصباح
العربيه رينادويه بيروت
على كلنا نورنا في الاستوديو وفريق مسرحيه
مفروكا مروه خليل ووفاء حلاوي والمخرج
رياض شيرازي اهلا بكم جميعا نورتونا في
الاستوديو اهلا بكم
اهلا طيب وفاء ابدا معاك من هذه المسرحيه
تندرج في اطار المسرح الهادف هذه المره
كان عنوانها المطلقات في لبنان تسلط الضوء
على مشاكل المطلقات نبدا من الفكره تحديدا
لماذا اختيرت هذه الفكره هي الفكره اذا
بدك بتكمل فكره فكره مسرحيه عملناها انا
ومروه من كم سنه اسمها جنود الست بتحكي عن
المراه اللي بالبيت ست البيت
فهذا الست البيت امل قررت تطلق فهي نفس
الشخصيه بهذه المس شخصيه واحده من مسالها
ثلاث ممثلات مروه خليل سيرينا شامي
بس كمان انا بدي افهم شغله انه مفروكه طب
احنا بنعرف مفروكه حلو وكثير طيب المذاق
يعني
هي مفروكه لانه انفركت انفركت بحياتها
وفركتها كمان زيت الوقت وبزيت الوقت كمان
عم نلعب على فكره
مثل مره شوي بالمسرحيه يعني مثل ما
بتعرفوا انه
في مساج قوي في رساله
يعني مدعوكي مضبوط صح فهيدا المعنى كمان
اللي كنا
رياض اللي بيشوف المسرحيه يشوف انها عكست
انه الرجال كلهم
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
اسمها لانه هي رحله امل والم يعني بالعكس
نحن عم ننقل معاناه معينه وخاصه هذا الشيء
واقعي هذا ما جاي من من العدم واقعي لانه
المراه تعاني
بهالشي بالزيت يعني خاصه لما نيجي لموضوع
الطلاق كثير في معاناه خاصه بالقوانين
الموجوده اللي ممكن ما تنصفها قد ما بتنصف
الرجل وبالتالي يمكن هذا موضوع نحن لازم
نحمله
جواتنا وبقلبنا لحتى بعتقد الرجل هو شريك
بهذا الشيء الشريك انه هو يلاقي الحل وهذا
موضوع داخل اللبناني وايضا يمثل مواضيع
كمان تتعلق المراه في خارج لبنان ولكن
لغير اللبنانيين وفا ومروه يعني انا حابه
وجهه نظركم بهالموضوع اللي شايفين الصوره
لبنان من برا يعتبروا انه لبنان بلد
الحريات لبنان بلد الانفتاح فمش قادرين
يقتنعوا او يصدقوا انه هل فعلا المراه في
لبنان مستضعفه المراه لا تاخذ حقوقها كيف
راح تقنعوهم خصوصا اننيا يعني في كثير
عالم بيشوفوا انه نحن يمكن بالحياه
اليوميه بشوفوا المراه حره اكثر يمكن بس
قانونيا مش مضبوط هذا الشيء وفي شيء كمان
كثير مميز بلبنان اللي هو عدم قانون موحد
للاحوال الشخصيه اوكي طيب
منفتح بس بعد ما عملنا ريسيرتش عرفنا انه
نحنا من اخر بلاد يعني المغرب ومصر قبل
قبل نحن تقريبا قد ايه كان بالجندر
اكواليتي نحنا الكلبنان
بعد كل المسرحيات السابقه للمفروكه اليوم
المسرحيه الجديده تجدد
فيها
جهه انه امراه قويه بدها تكون ضعيفه فيها
تضحك على حالها امرار وكذا فحبينا
انه اخترنا انه نكون ثلاثه لانه مفرجي كذا
وجه لهالشخصيه طيب رياض مروه وفاه تحدثوا
عن الطابع الكوميدي اخراجيا هل تعتقد انه
الطابع الكوميديه يصل الى قلوب المشاهد
اكثر يوصل الرساله هو هون دايما في شغله
مهمه بالمسرح يعني اللي بده يحضر مسرح
وهادئ اذا التركيبه انوجدت هي بتعطي يمكن
الوصفه السحريه بسميها انه الواحد يروح
على المسرح يفكر
يحس ويستمتع
بهالمسرحيه بعتقد قدرنا نوصل لهالمحل نخلي
العالم تفكر العالم بتحس
وهاي التركيبه السحريه يعني كان دائما اذا
لاحظتوا دائما بالمسرحيه كان توصلي لحدود
البيكن وقف وننقل بس لحتى يضل الواحد عم
يفكر توصل حدود الضحك نوقف وننقل هذا كتير
مهم لحتى تضل عم تفكر مش نغرق بس بنحطه
باطار كوميديا سوداء بنقدر نقول فيك
تحطيها باطار كوميديا سوداء فيك يعني فيها
هي خليط كثير لذيذ من من صور ومن من يعني
انا دائما بقول لهم مثل كانك قاعده بخلاط
مشاعر خلاص يعني بتضحكي وبتبكي
وبتصرخي يعني اللي عم يطلع منه عم يحس
حاله بقلب اعصار من المشاعر عم يطلع مش
عارف اي شعور بده يحس
[موسيقى]
المسرحيه كلها هي توعيه المراه بحقوقها في
المجتمع ماذا تقولين المراه اللبنانيه في
عيدها اليوم
اكيد بتمنى لها حقوقها بتمنى بتمنى
نحن عم نحكي عن مجتمع ذكوري بس لازم نتذكر
انه الذكوريه مش يعني مش بس الرجال بكون
ذكوري مرات المراه بتكون ذكوريه فبتمنى
للمراه تكون اخت
لكل النساء اللي حواليها واللي بتعرفهم
يعني
كل النساء سواء واكيد كمان مع الرجال شكرا
جزيلا